prevented more than 35 million covid
cases this is not by accident the
president made it his top priority to
make sure vaccines were readily
available to americans as early as
possible he deployed the national guard
activated fema and began a smooth
process to distribute vaccines to
trusted locations like pharmacies and
community health centers he passed the
historic american rescue plan that
ensured we could continue to have the
resources needed to expand and
accelerate our vaccination campaign and
he's taken both steps like vaccine
requirements to accelerate vaccinations
when they slow down we know the
vaccinations save lives and for those
fully vaccinated boosters are critical
and this is further evidence about the
impact just wanted to provide another
brief update
on our work in helping address the storm
rescue and recovery efforts the
president approved emergency disaster
declarations for illinois and tennessee
last night in addition to the major
disaster declaration he approved for
kentucky to support recovery efforts
fema has teams of urban search and
rescue and emergency response personnel
in kentucky supporting search and rescue
efforts along with disaster survivor
assistance teams to help survivors
register for assistance fema has sent
dozens of generators to kentucky along
with 135 000 gallon liters of water 74
000 meals and thousands of cots blankets
infant toddler kits and pandemic shelter
kits to support the people of kentucky
and finally the u.s army corps of
engineers personnel are providing debris
removal infrastructure assessment and
power restoration support and mobile
emergency response support personnel are
on the ground in kentucky to provide
emergency communications capabilities as
needed and of course we'll continue to
provide updates to all of you josh why
don't you kick us off thanks jen two
questions
first uh is the president meeting again
with senator manchin and what was so
constructive in their conversation
yesterday
that caused this thing
that caused the meeting or it led to
this follow-up meeting what what was the
progress what was the forward momentum
sure uh well as you heard uh our
spokespeople say and senator manchin
convey yesterday they had a constructive
and productive meeting yesterday and
continued the conversation about how to
lower costs for the american people
across the country we're not quite there
yet uh hence the conversations will
continue both at a staff level and
certainly with uh senator manchin
directly i don't have anything in terms
of a call or meeting to announce that's
scheduled at this point but you heard
them both convey they're going to be in
touch and we expect that to be the case
in the coming days and then secondly
congress is going to vote on increasing
the debt limit
why does president biden believe it's
better politically and economically to
increase the debt limit rather than
scrap it entirely
i know there are some proposing that i
would note that the debt limit has now
been raised 82 times am i right in my
mouth there 82 times now
more than 80. that's probably a safe way
to say it um and that it represents a
shared uh responsibility to pay for past
spending by both parties uh there's
plenty of time for conversations about
what it should look like moving forward
but there's no question it's a good sign
that we are not going to be on the brink
of defaulting uh our u.s economy uh or
sending the us economy into a reception
a recession jeopardizing social security
benefits payments to our troops or other
critical functions of government so
there's no question josh i expect that
those who have alternate ideas or
proposals for the debt limit limit
moving forward may be outspoken of those
moving forward but certainly this is a
good sign that we're going to avoid a
default uh and putting all those
payments at risk go ahead um california
is bringing back statewide indoor mass
mandates
should other states consider similar
action
we really leave it to leaders in states
to make decisions about what needs to be
done to keep communities safe our advice
continues to be to follow the guidance
of the cdc and our public health
officials and that advice is based on it
continues to be that if you're in
moderate or high transmission areas uh
they have specific recommendations about
how to keep communities safe uh in
october you suggest that that finance
was gonna speak on the filibuster
and he said in the upcoming week for
something along those lines any guidance
on timing when he will speak on that and
what he may say
i don't have any updates on timing nor
am i going to get ahead of the president
himself but certainly getting voting
rights done is something that he has
committed to and is eager to get passed
and signed into law last question any
any response to the revolut revelations
that uh
that gop lawmakers uh were texting uh
chief of staff meadows along with
prominent fox news hosts ahead of the uh
during the january six riots well it's
disappointing and unfortunately not
surprising that some of the very same
individuals who are willing to warn
condemn and express horror over what
happened on january 6th in private we're
totally in private we're totally silent
and public
or even worse
we're spreading lies and conspiracy
theories and continue to since that time
so disappointing not surprising
unfortunately we've seen a trend from
some of the same individuals go ahead
it's been one week since the president
had his virtual conversation with
president putin have you seen anything
that leads you to believe there has been
a de-escalation and also i know both
presidents have tasked their teams to
continue conversations can you outline
any of those conversations
let me let me give you an update on that
uh phil in terms of the ongoing
conversations um
so um
as i noted yesterday but let me give you
an update on what's happening today we
are continuing to consult closely with
our european allies and partners to
determine the best format for the
security talks that president biden and
president putin agreed to and we're
consulting closely uh with our partners
on how to proceed so
as part of that obviously our secretary
of state uh was meeting with his
counterparts over the weekend for
pre-planned meetings our assistant
secretary of state karen donfried was
just in key for meetings with ukrainian
leaders and to reinforce the united
states commitment to ukraine's
sovereignty territorial integrity and
discuss the path forward today she's in
moscow to meet with russian leaders to
express our concerns about russian's
escalation of forces surrounding ukraine
and to speak directly with senior
russian officials and underscore our
commitment to help resolve the conflict
in eastern ukraine so those
conversations are a reflection of the
follow-on that we uh expected and
predicted uh following the conversations
last week of course our objective
continues to keep be to keep this on a
diplomatic path and to lead for that to
lead to de-escalation
of de-escalation troops pulling out or
signs from russian officials that they
are stepping back to some degree
again we're watching this closely i
don't have any updates on that from here
but it is a good sign that there are
diplomatic engagements and discussions
that are continuing including with
russian leaders and officials ukrainians
and our european partners
better is the president kind of in this
moment um of the mind that the final
package will look like whatever can get
50 votes
that's usually how it works isn't it
what you've laid out i didn't mean to
give you a hard time um
yes look look i think the president um
is the first to say having done this
sent as a senator for 36 years that
progress often requires compromise and
you've seen that already to date
what we're talking about now does not
look like his original proposal
so there's already been a significant
amount of compromise he's come down in
numbers in some of the areas that were
in his original proposal
and he's comfortable with that because
he knows in order to make progress
compromise can't be treated as a dirty
word we're still in that process now now
we're much farther along than we were uh
a month or two months ago uh but those
conversations are con continuing
obviously with senator manchin yesterday
and others as we work to get this bill
across the finish line go ahead you know
that you've made some progress but
you're not there yet uh following the
conversation with mentioned yesterday is
the president more or less optimistic
that you can get there uh before the end
of the year
well uh i'm just gonna quote two
important players in this effort and
what they said yesterday uh leader
schumer said the work is not yet
finished but we're working hard to put
the senate in a position to get the
legislation across the finish line
before christmas and we've seen
we trust his leadership and his efforts
to get this done senator manchin said
we're just talking about different
iterations that's all we're engaged
let's at least see the bill see the what
they write what's the final print i
would also note mary in terms of the
process that uh the parliamentarian
still needs to rule on components before
the bill would go to the floor so right
now we're right in the thick of it we're
working to get it done uh and of course
the president is eager to see it passed
into law and signed so that we can give
relief to the american people but i
can't make more predictions beyond that
and on the president's trip tomorrow to
kentucky can you give us any more sort
of update or guidance on what he may be
doing uh will we be hearing from him is
the first lady or any member of congress
going to be traveling with him so i can
confirm that he invited the kentucky
delegation to travel with him i would
leave it to them to convey their travel
plans it's only natural and
understandable that some of them may
have alternate plans either to have been
there in advance or go later so we'll
leave that to them and as is standard
we'll provide all of you a manifest list
uh tomorrow
i would say that while the president is
there um he will be
serving storm damage firsthand making
sure that we're doing everything to
deliver assistance as quickly as
possible to impacted areas to support
recovery efforts i can tell you from
traveling on some of these trips with
the president in the past often what
happens is he will ask leaders directly
what do you need what are you not
getting and how can we make it faster
for you and then he will get back in the
car and he will give an assignment to a
staffer and say get this done even me i
don't always know but i figure it out uh
so that is how i would expect he would
will approach this he's going to be
joined by governor beshear uh secretary
mayorkus who is just there his fema
administrator who's who is just there
will also join him and he wants those on
the ground to know the federal
government is there to provide whatever
support is needed for them you'll also
see him make brief remarks and provide
an update as well and also engage with
people who have been impacted uh
directly by these storms
one more thing um today is the first
anniversary of the first shots uh going
into arms last year uh i'm wondering if
you can get your reaction to something
that the democratic uh governor colorado
said last week about the vaccines he
said this has brought the end of the
medical emergency as it relates to the
virus he says those who get sick it's
almost entirely their own darn fault i'm
wondering if the president agrees with
that
i i would i would say those are not the
president words the president has used
or would use um you know the president
believes that his responsibility
continues to be uh providing access
providing information uh to the american
people even those who are hesitant even
those who did not vote for him even
those who have not yet received a shot
because more people are still getting
shots more people are still getting
boosted and his responsibility is to
continue to take steps to protect the
american people uh so that would be his
view go ahead another on vaccines does
the president comment on the first
group of service members who've been
discharged for refusing to get
the cover back
so i know um i'd of course refer you
overall to the department of defense my
understanding is that 99 of the air
force is in compliance so we're talking
about
less than one percent um which to us the
story is that it's more than 99 who are
in compliance uh i would also note they
can give you more detail on this but
this is at the end of months of
counseling and engagement with those not
getting compliance about what is
required here and of course there were
people who were granted exemptions who
applied for those in granted exemptions
as the secretary of defense said the
requirement will help ensure readiness
which is what the american people expect
from their armed forces and we're
certainly encouraged by the high level
of compliance from the department last
night a federal appeals court upheld the
ruling that required the administration
to reinstate the remaining mexico border
policy
you know if there's any plan for the
administration to file an appeal to the
supreme court to finally settle
once and for all whether this policy
still needs to exist well you know where
we stand from a policy
standpoint on this uh we believe it's
ineffective inhumane and the secretary
of homeland security has conveyed
multiple memos in that regard which is
of course consistent with the
president's view i'd point to the
department of justice for any legal
plans uh but certainly uh you know we
note uh that decision this morning and
obviously would reiterate that uh this
is a well this is a program that that we
disagree with the junction uh dictating
courtyard implementation remains in
effect so we continue to comply with it
in good faith there is another policy
that's in place that the court didn't
require you to put in place and that is
title 42
i'm just curious if that
is the plan is to keep it in place going
into next year
uh that guidance is determined by the
cdc and our health experts uh based on
whether or not we're in the middle of a
fight against a global pandemic and we
continue to be but i'd really defer to
them on
any plans or decisions to change those
requirements
from overseas um curious if the
administration has any comment on the
case of sergey
forgive me for getting response
tickanovsky the fellow russian
opposition leader who was apparently
been sentenced to 18 years in jail now
for organizing protests against
president lukashenko well we have in in
the past let me just reiterate our
deep concern about any crackdowns on
freedom of speech is freedom of
expression uh the right of freedom of
speech by opposition leaders i have not
spoken about this particular case with
our national security team i'm happy to
do that ed and get you a
a more comprehensive comment and the
pronunciation which i'm not sure of
either so we'll get you that too go
ahead thank you jen why is it that there
are still americans stranded in
afghanistan
well i think uh let me just reiterate
something that tony blinken said back in
august which is that if americans who
are in afghanistan wanted to leave
whether it was three weeks from now a
month from now two months from now back
in august we would help them get out and
that is something that we've delivered
on our word on i would note that since
that time we've directly assisted 479
american citizens 450 lawful permanent
residents and sav holders and sav
applicants to depart afghanistan uh that
was that's important to convey because
it's uh it's important for people to
understand who were there that even if
they decided not to even if they decided
not to today we are still going to help
them depart and there's evidence of that
okay 479
left behind is a lot higher than the 100
to 200 that president biden was talking
about at the end of 479 who we've helped
depart from since august he said uh that
he thought that there were we believe
there are 100 200 uh with some intention
to leave so how did the number how did
you guys get them there were people who
wanted determined they wanted to leave
since then and it is our responsibility
to help them depart so that's evidence
of our commitment to do exactly that and
is this something as there are now at
least or about a dozen who want to leave
right now is this something the
president works on every day
certainly he receives regular updates
from his team and we the state
department and other national security
officials really really lead this effort
i would just reiterate that the united
states does not track or put a tracker
on american citizens traveling overseas
whether they're in afghanistan or any
country around the world that would be
quite a fox news story wouldn't it be if
we did that we don't do that but we do
provide a range of services even when we
don't have a presence in a country and
our efforts to get american citizens out
of afghanistan many of them dual
citizens many of them have lived their
whole lives there since that time is
evidence of that thank you and then
following up on something that you said
yesterday when you say that we've seen
an increase in crime over the course of
the pandemic there are a range of
reasons for that
would you consider one of the reasons in
the range prosecutors who are cutting
people who are accused of many criminal
offenses loose too quickly
i again i am not as i as i wasn't
yesterday going to give an assessment
for every uh every every motivation or
reason for crime in different
communities across the country what i've
noted what you see in data is that there
has been an increase in crime since the
start of the pandemic i will let others
assess with the reason for that increase
in crime is uh that is all i was
conveying yesterday okay there are some
reports that these smash and grab
robberies are being organized on social
media platforms is the administration
doing anything about that
we we are monitoring of course these
thefts very closely as we've talked
about a bit in here the videos and
reports we're seeing are very troubling
uh our state and local law enforcement
partners have primary jurisdiction over
break-ins and robberies of this kind but
i can say we're
aggressively using every resource at our
disposal in terms of how they're being
organized or orchestrated we'd really
refer you to our law enforcement
authorities fbi doj and other local
authorities on that and last one the
reason that i ask you guys have not been
afraid to call out social media
companies like when you thought that
they were a platform for covid
disinformation you said that that was a
public health matter
why not call them out for this do you
not consider this a public health matter
well we believe that there should be
investigations that should occur to
determine the origin and what prompted
uh any of these uh thefts and so we've
offered the fbi and doj are in contact
with affected jurisdictions to offer
assistance with investigations including
and identifying how these incidents are
planned and organized uh and certainly
we don't believe any platform should be
used to conduct robbery or theft go
ahead as you know this is a very hard
day and anniversary nine years since
the awful shootings that took place at
sandy hook the president's obviously
face fierce criticism and resistance
from republicans on new gun restrictions
in his efforts he likes to say that he
tells it straight to the american people
even when it's not convenient does the
president concede that another year is
likely to pass without meaningful
legislative action on guns
well the president's never going to
predict a lack of progress for a year
ahead of time i will tell you i will
reiterate though that the president has
not uh has taken more steps using his
executive authority at by this point in
a presidency than any president in
history because he believes more needs
to be done to address gun safety and on
a day like today and hopefully you all
saw the video released of the president
marking today
it's a reminder of the fact that more
progress needs to be made that uh there
are steps that need to be taken whether
it's banning assault weapons whether
it's ensuring that there are
that gun manufacturers should be held
accountable whether it is putting in
place universal background checks these
are all steps that the president would
support he is also encouraged though by
the fact that there are some states that
have taken initiative to put in place
assault weapons bans to put in place
red flag laws that we know could have
prevented some of these uh of these
tragic circumstances and he is going to
continue to look at more work that can
be done so we can't predict but clearly
the political capital as you witness is
not there he was in charge of this when
he was the vice president however many
years ago as well and witnessed the
roadblocks that iran to ran into many
times from republicans so what needs to
change
well i would say first he's encouraged
by the activism that we've seen across
the country and the impact he believes
that has had on state laws that have
changed i would also note that he has
not waited uh and he has taken steps to
arraign the proliferation of gut ghost
guns better
regulation of stabilizing braces
encouraging states to adopt laws as i
noted and he's going to continue to
press and encourage action on existing
legislation the violence against women
act uh
requirement of background checks and gun
sales and even build back better which
of course we're talking about and trying
to get it
trying to get it signed that would
invest five billion dollars in
evidence-based community violence
initiative so his interventions he's
going to continue to look for ways to
make progress even as uh there is
obstruction by some in congress when he
heads to an in-person fundraiser tonight
i can't think of the last one that he's
done this may be the first one in the
course of his time in office you can
tell me if there's another that i'm
missing here as we're speaking about
in-person events just because a lot of
people look to the white house for sort
of guidance on these things as an
example what is the white house's
position on holiday parties taking place
here how are you guys handling that have
you changed your position are they not
happening what are you doing differently
uh we're celebrating the holidays here
at the white house this year through a
variety of ways uh first lady received
the annual
arrival of the christmas tree of course
unveiled the holiday
decorations the president the first lady
the vice president and the second
gentleman hosted the national tree
lighting we're also going to be hosting
uh some holiday open houses inviting
guests to see the holiday decorations in
person in the coming days
of course we're going to continue to
implement covid protocol so it doesn't
look exactly like it has always looked
here but we are going to continue to
celebrate to embrace uh the holiday
season and look for ways we can do that
go ahead thanks jen on january 6th are
you or has the president taken the time
to personally review any of the records
of his predecessor on that day
well uh this is really something that's
done primarily through the white house
counsel's office as should be
appropriate uh can you tell us that the
public schedule that you guys put out
last night rather than today what is the
president doing today
well let's see uh the president has two
local interviews he will be doing later
this afternoon uh he has a number of
internal meetings with senior members of
his staff that have happened throughout
the course of the day today his uh
presidential daily brief uh and i
believe there's some mayors who are uh
visiting today as well what's the
purpose of the meeting with the mayors
it's not a meeting with the president
the mayors they're here i'm not going to
get ahead of it beyond that but he has a
full schedule today go ahead
thank you jen i wanted to follow up on
guns and tell sure governor newsom is
pursuing a proposal that would allow
private citizens to sue anyone who
manufactures sells or distributes
assault weapons in the state it's based
on the legal framework that was used in
the texas law event abortion after six
weeks does the white house support
governor newson's approach here
well first um i'd note there's no
legislative text in california it's a
proposal or something that's being
discussed the president has long
expressed his support for an assault
weapons ban he's called on congress to
pass a ban on assault weapons and
high-capacity magazines he'd like that
to be done at a federal level he's also
taken action to reign in ghost guns
called on congress to keep guns out of
the hands of abusers take another strong
executive actions to keep people safe
from gun violence he's also made clear
over the last several months that he
believes that sb-8 is not only an attack
on women's reproductive rights but that
he will continue to fight for one's
long-recognized constitutional right
under roe v wade i know that part of
what has been proposed here is about
immunity from liability uh the president
has uh supported in the past
the uh repeal of uh of the uh liability
of plcaa which is something would be a
special immunity for gun dealers and
subjected to the same type of lawsuits
faced by all other businesses that's
something that could certainly move
forward in congress but i don't have any
response to a specific proposal that
isn't legislative yet and if you know
the president mark the san diego
anniversary he's called on the senate
senate to pass gender gun laws but what
are you doing what is he doing himself
to crawl votes and given the gridlock
would he support a filibuster carve out
uh to get something done legislation i
don't have anything new to report to all
of you on the president's position on
legislative processes but i would just
reiterate the fact that the president
has long been an advocate for common
sense gun reform measures he led the
effort to get the brady bill passed to
put an assault weapons ban in place to
get universal background checks passed
to put in place dozens of executive
actions when he was vice president and
has done more than any president in
history at this point in his presidency
to use his executive authority to take
action on guns go ahead
what is the white house planning to do
if anything to commemorate january 6th i
feel like there's been a little
push and pull internally at the white
house you know not necessarily wanting
to elevate former president trump but
also wanting to
respond to some of the threats so how
are you all approaching that i don't
want anything to report to you at this
point in time about our plans i expect
we will have more uh as we get closer to
the end of the year
but you know the president to the
president january 6th was
one of the darkest days in our democracy
uh it was a day that our our capital our
nation's capital was under attack and i
think there's no question you'll see us
commemorate that day
sure on monday russia said that it may
be forced to deploy intermediate uh
ranged nuclear missiles in europe in
response to nato's plans to potentially
do the same and i'm wondering what is
the white house's response to that
i would just reiterate that nato is a
defensive alliance nothing has changed
in that regard despite the rhetoric of
the russians or other leaders around the
world
we have spoken about the importance of
engaging in de-escalation and diplomacy
uh now is not to the time to take steps
that would do the opposite uh so we
remain uh focused on diplomacy on
engaging uh with our nato partners
engaging with europeans engaging with
the ukrainians and the russians as i
just outlined we are doing even as we
speak go ahead thanks john um lawmakers
reached a deal on the uyghur forced
labor legislation
can you just share a little bit about
what the administration's concerns were
with the original legislation what
compromises the administration saw
i certainly understand the question but
i don't think i'm going to get into the
details of the legislative
behind-the-scenes discussions our effort
is to often provide technical assistance
to ensure that uh that bills are are
implementable but if the president will
sign the bill uh we have been clear that
we share congress's view that action
must be taken to hold the prc
accountable for its human rights abuses
and to address forced labor in xinjiang
we've already taken action on the global
stage
in that regard leading an effort that g7
putting in place uh financial sanctions
and global inputting and
global magnitude visa restrictions and i
think that's evidence of our commitment
to this on travel restrictions for south
africa and some of the neighbors
given the widespread transmission in
europe and omicron cases
in the u.s any update that you can
provide on when the administration may
modify or even lift those restrictions
well the country-based restrictions were
intended to be temporary to buy time not
a longer-term restrictions uh not
longer-term restrictions and as we said
at the beginning we're going to look at
a range of data including our own that
process is still ongoing and we're
watching three areas closely vaccine
effectiveness transmissibility and
severity and we'll continue to adapt our
approach to travel restrictions as more
data comes in i don't have any updates
today on the timing but certainly again
just to reiterate our intention is not
for these to be permanent and we're
evaluating when we can lift them
can i ask one more question on student
loans um i think you said last week that
you're working on a plan to help
students pay um but what about president
biden's campaign to forgive or cancel
ten thousand dollars in student-led debt
pardon me um you know what is the
message to the people who feel uh that
he's yet to follow through on that
problem congress sends him a bill he's
happy to sign it
they haven't sent him a bill on that yet
go ahead thanks jen uh two questions
first one on kentucky when the president
travels tomorrow he's going to be going
forward and devoted overwhelmingly for
former president trump he said yesterday
he wants to be a source of comfort when
he's there can you talk a little bit
about how he prepares to go to what
seems like it's going to be the most you
know conservative area of the country
that he's traveled to as president
and does it make it harder to be that
source of comfort given how much
polarization and political division
we're seeing at this moment right now uh
no i think the president looks at people
through
the tragedy they're experiencing uh the
heartache they're feeling at the loss of
life the loss of their homes
uh questions many people are raising i
know about whether they can build back
from
this this storm that's impacted their
communities he looks at them as human
beings not as people who have partisan
affiliations uh and uh in his heart he
has empathy for everything that they're
going through and the message he's going
to send to them directly and clearly
tomorrow is we're here to help we want
to rebuild we are going to stand by your
side and we're going to help your
leaders do exactly that uh so no i
wouldn't say it's hard to prepare i
would say the president just wants to
send a clear message and stand by people
in these communities as they're going
through this difficult time and then
secondly just to follow up on peter's
question about the holiday parties i
know you said it's going to look a
little different than it has does that
mean the president is foregoing the sort
of traditional parties the president's
host for members of congress and others
and if so is that due to a specific
reason is it the new variant is it the
state of the pandemic and infections in
general what is that sort of you know
different kind of holiday schedules i
touched on a little before it's more
we're going to be having some open
houses uh which a range of people will
be invited to those open houses have the
opportunity to see the decorations and
see
the east wing decorated and the
christmas tree that the first lady
welcomed just a few weeks ago
obviously we're still in the middle of a
pandemic we're still taking precautions
as it relates to
large events big visitors etc
go ahead
there are several progressive groups and
lawmakers who are
increasingly vocalizing the idea that
inflation high inflation is being driven
by corporate greed
including companies with high profits
some of whom have met at the white house
with the president in recent months um
does the president endorse that idea
does he think the corporate greed is the
big driver of inflation right now well i
think the president thinks the way
people across the country american
families
digest inflation is by price increases
and if you look at industry to industry
it's a little different so for example
the president the secretary of
agriculture have both spoken to what
we've seen as the greed of meat
conglomerates that is an area where
people go to the grocery store and
they're trying to buy a pound of meat
two pounds of meat 10 pounds of meat
it is the prices are higher that is in
his view
and the view of our secretary of
agriculture because of you could call it
corporate greed short you could call it
jacking up prices uh uh
during a pandemic uh there are other
areas where we've seen increases uh
because of supply chain issues and we're
seeing those increases around the world
as it relates to gas prices uh oil
supply and things along those lines so i
would say there's some areas where we
have seen uh corporations uh benefit
profit from the pandemic uh and uh and
certainly the president would agree with
that component i i don't know the full
context of all of their remarks and then
uh somehow related
when the president was interviewing
candidates including uh his eventual
selection for the fed chair
did he express any preferences about the
the path of interest rates or
tapering or any other monetary policy in
the coming months uh he certainly defers
to the independence of the federal
reserve and the chair uh and in any
engagements he has with them
go ahead thanks john the supermarket
chain kroger announced it will stop
giving paid leave to unvaccinated
workers if they get coveted is this an
approach that the white house supports
what's your response to that we know
different private sector companies and
entities are going to take different
steps to incentivize people to get
vaccinated to keep their employees safe
and their workforce safe but i don't
have any further it's not a
recommendation not a policy we're
putting out there from the federal
government does the white house support
private companies imposing penalties
like insurance surcharges or other
methods to try to get people vaccinated
that's not something we have put out
from the federal government but again
we're not going to comment on every
single policy made by every private
sector entity just a quick follow-up on
the debt limit what do you say to
americans who see this as yet another
example of congress kicking the can down
the road
uh well i would say that uh in what way
i'm not sure who who's saying that until
2023 but it's going to come up again
right after the midterms what do you say
to people who say we're just going to be
having the same conversation a little
bit over a year from now
i'm not sure what american person is
saying that or is concerned about the
debt limit but maybe there's somebody
you've met on the street i don't know
but i will say that
you know our view the president's view
is that this has been done in a
bipartisan way the american people
shouldn't be worried about whether or
not elected officials are doing what
they should do and raising the debt
limit to make sure we're covering bills
that have already been incurred which i
think is sometimes a misunderstanding
out there we're not talking about future
spending or the size of the buildback
better package i'm not saying you're
suggesting that at all um and that you
know i think the president would uh
would convey that uh this is something
that should just be done in due course
as it's been done more than 80 times to
quote josh in the past
and that it shouldn't be something that
consumes weeks months of time it should
be done because we want to avoid default
we want to ensure people are getting
their social security benefits that
retirees are being paid military and
that there's no risk to the u.s economy
go ahead so with regard to russia you've
said several times that you and
president allies are working to move
this towards the diplomacy but when jake
was in the briefing room last week he
said a couple times
the way to assess whether there's
progress is seeing changes in the facts
on the
along the border it's been a week he
said you look for that within a matter
of days has the administration seen any
changes with regard to the presence of
russian troops on the border i don't
have any additional assessments we
obviously watch that closely from here
to make from the podium but what i think
it's important to note is what we're
working to prevent or deter which is the
invasion of ukraine by russia right and
we are looking to continue these
diplomatic conversations to deter that
and send very clear message through a
coordinated
meetings engagements with our european
partners that there would be significant
and severe consequences should they move
forward how long i guess is the
administration willing to accept the
current status quo because i know
there's a red line if russia invades
ukraine but what if
the troop numbers just sort of stay the
same at the border indefinitely i know
you're looking to see
some movement from from russia how long
is the current situation i'm not going
to give you a timeline from here uh
we're obviously engaged in daily
conversations with europeans with
russians with ukrainians and conveying
exactly what we think should happen here
to de-escalate the situation on the
ground but i'm not going to give you a
timeline or a deadline from here go
ahead thanks jeff uh amtrak just now
announced that they are suspending their
vaccine mandate they had said they were
requiring workers to vaccinate they
suggested they might even be service
cuts because they would not have enough
staffing uh they're now suggesting uh
they would once again revert and allow
testing to be uh an acceptable
alternative is white house of reaction
to this well i would say that a number
of private sector companies including
our own recommendations would have have
vaccination or testing options
the last data i saw
was that 96 of amtrak employees had been
vaccinated that's a pretty high number
so i guess they're talking about the
remaining four percent uh and they're
trying to work to ensure that there are
adequate employees on the job i would
also note that i know there was some
reporting uh last week about um delays
potential amtrak delays which i think
they attributed to issues outside of the
vaccination requirements and not that so
the last date i saw was 96
certainly vaccination or testing is
something we have been recommending from
the federal government so i don't think
we have any concern that's the subject
near and dear to the president's heart
oh yeah
overseas um
the united kingdom has been really under
siege um from the new variant of the
coronavirus uh there's been dire
warnings from the prime minister the new
restrictions put in place can you talk
about whether there's been increased
consultation between administration
officials here and their counterparts uh
in the uk about what they're seeing with
this new variant and any plans for
conversation between the president and
the prime minister
i don't have any uh conversation between
the president the prime minister to
predict although we certainly remain
open to leader to leader engagement as
does the president if that's what his
team is is recommending at this point we
do have regular consultations with
health officials from around the world
whether it's european countries the
united kingdom countries in africa about
what we're seeing
as it relates to this variant because
different countries have different data
we're using some of that data and
assessing some of that data even as we
have our own and some countries are
ahead or behind where we may be so those
consultations are primarily happening
between health officials but they are
ongoing and are important part of our
assessment and our preparations here
go in the middle thanks jen um two quick
questions the first with dr valjee's
previous statements about the potential
for additional boosters do we know what
longitudinal data
pfizer is collecting to determine what
the impact of increased frequency of
vaccines may have on our health
do you so just so i understand your
question are you asking about what
what a booster what data we are relying
on for one why a booster would help on
the the data that what pfizer is
collecting to talk about the frequency
of the shots that we're not talking
about so you have the first set and now
you have this one but are we is there
any data that we know about the study
that they're collecting information that
they're collecting to get a third shot
or to something different about the
impact that it will have on our health
the number of shots that we're getting
i'm sorry i'm not totally understanding
your question but but we have our own
data we assess that the cdc and the f
and other health officials in the us
government they they consult closely
with pfizer with moderna with all of
these pharmaceutical companies to ensure
that they're looking at their data as
well
and we of course they make
recommendations whenever they think
there needs to be an additional
shot so they made a recommendation about
the efficacy of boosters
that is something we have seen uh have
provide additional protection from the
delta variant which is still the
predominant variant and we also and
you've seen dr fauci say that that
provides additional protection as it
relates to the omicron variant as well
uh we haven't made any change in terms
of what at this point fully vaccinated
means but dr faucis are as also said
sorry that it's not a matter of if but
when the second question um
is is the president planning any
clemency grants um before christmas i
know we haven't heard anything about two
months he was saying that the white
house was reviewing commutations for
those on home confinement is there any
update uh let me check with our um with
our council's office and see if there's
any update i know we've talked about
this before and his intention of uh
using uh clemency but i don't have any
update on the timeline of that go ahead
thanks jen a couple quick ones for you
on kentucky tomorrow will the president
meet directly with anyone who's lost
their homes can you provide more
specifics on that direct engagement he
certainly will uh engage with people who
have lost a lot have maybe have lost
loved ones lost their homes i don't know
what exact traffic tragic circumstances
individuals will have but these
communities have been broadly impacted
and as you know he's going to
communities that were the hardest hit by
the storm
and then on the expanded child tax
credit does the white house have a
backup plan if buildback better does not
pass this week to make sure that those
payments continue to be made into the
new year
well our intention and our hope is
certainly to get bill back better done
i think if you're asking me if the child
tax credit could be peeled off i think
is that if that's what you're asking me
others were asking me this yesterday
again our focus on the legislative front
is on bill back better and getting it
done i would note there have been some
republicans who have said they might
support child tax credit in the past i'd
point you all it's out there to report
on what they would or wouldn't support
but that would require 60 votes okay
lastly the house is expected today to
recommend that former white house chief
of staff mark meadows uh face criminal
prosecution for contempt does the
president believe that the department of
justice should prosecute mark meadows we
leave that to the department of justice
uh go ahead
thank you jen um so you said
the social spending package would lower
costs uh in various areas like child
care but would it lower inflation
that's what uh
dozens of economists have said
even though like child care could go
down but food prices could go up they
believe that the more the spending that
happens the food prices could come back
down as well as the other things people
are buying well 56 economists say that
buildback better will help quote
alleviate some of the strain caused by
inflation and i think what's important
to note here is and you're an economic
expert of sorts even if you play one on
tv but i know you actually are uh is
that as we talk about inflation and data
a very important way to look at it and
evaluate look at the federal reserve
projections
american people how they're experiencing
this at home is a rise in costs in
different areas right whether it's meat
prices when they're buying burgers or
gas prices or other areas so
why we why we explain
buildback better the way we do is to
convey exactly the areas to the american
public where it will lower costs child
care is a huge cost burden on a lot of
families across the country and it will
have an immediate impact next year
go ahead
thank you jen um two foreign policy
questions the first one is year ender
season so i would ask you what does the
administration consider your biggest
achievement in foreign policy in this
first year and also what lessons have
you learned from what is arguably the
biggest failure which is afghanistan
you know this is a great question i want
to be thoughtful about i want to talk to
the president about it and i'm happy to
do that go ahead can i follow up on um
yeah china there's a washington post
report that says that huawei
actually has a bigger
role in china's state surveillance do
you have a reaction to that and are
there any additional plans for
restricting moral huawei products
i don't have anything new on that either
but i'll talk to our national security
team go ahead thank you a quick
follow-up when you were asked if the
president works in getting you know
these americans out of afghanistan every
day you said that he receives regular
updates um obviously this is still a top
priority for him right absolutely but i
think it's important for people to
understand the hard work that's being
done day in and day out is through our
diplomatic team the state department
team who are working on the ground
working with the military and others to
get americans out a second question um
the previous three administrations
publicly celebrated afghan women who
stood up to the taliban
in particular a number of former first
ladies
and the state department brought some of
these women's to washington and even
gave them the international women of
courage award
some are unfortunately stuck in
afghanistan right now
does the united states still have a
commitment to them
absolutely um
we we celebrate we honor the courage of
these women we are committed to
continuing to provide a range of
assistance and to working with a range
of non-profits and ngos around the world
and i don't know what's next for the
international element of courage a
really important celebration of courage
around the world
or nor can i predict that but certainly
a number of them would be great honorees
okay april um
one thing can we get your
take on the hearings many of us are
doing year in pieces
if when you give it make sure we all get
it yep um two questions
one on student debt forgiveness is the
president settle on ten thousand chuck
schumer wanted fifty is he settled on
that or is he looking for somewhere in
between
uh the president has said in the past
april that if some if a bill was sent to
his desk uh to uh
on ten thousand dollars he would sign
that into law there have been questions
and asks about what executive
authorities could be used that has been
under review i don't have anything to
report on that at this point in time
activists once again are trying to
tighten the vice
up and down pennsylvania avenue on
issues of voting rights i'm hearing from
sources here in the white house as well
as some activists that are saying that
joe manchin has suffered a bit on the
filibuster
can you comment on that is that the case
is that true and has he said that to the
president i will let senator manchin
speak for himself on his views on voting
rights in the filibuster
of the conversation with the president
of late has been about voting rights
with joe manchin they typically discuss
a range of uh topics i'm not gonna read
out their private conversations further
thanks everyone will the president have
a press conference anytime soon well
steve i will let you know if we do brian
thank you so much
you